- [Voiceover] Consider the
system of linear equations
above, which of the
following choices of a,
will result in a system of equations
with no solutions?
So a system has no solutions,
is if both lines, and these are both
linear equations, they actually tell us
these are linear equations,
is if you have two
lines that are parallel.
Then, you have no solutions.
They are never going to intersect,
there's no x, y pair that
satisfies both of them.
So if they are parallel, then you're going
to have no solutions.
So what makes two lines parallel?
Well, if they have the same slope,
but they have different y intercepts,
you're going to be parallel.
So essentially we need to pick the a here
that makes the second line
parallel to the first.
And to do that, I'm
going to actually write
both of them in kind of
the slope intercept form
where y is equal to the slope times x
plus the intercept.
So let's do that, let's
do that for both of these.
So first I'll do this one up here,
so you have nine x minus 14 y is equal
to negative three.
See, if I subtract nine x from both sides,
I would get negative 14 y is equal
to negative nine x minus three.
See, if I divide both
sides by negative 14,
I'm going to get y is
equal to negative nine
divided by negative 14
is positive nine over 14 x,
and then plus three over 14.
So that's this line, written
in slope intercept form.
Now let me write the second line
So I have two x minus ay,
is equal to negative six.
And let's see, if I subtract
two from both sides,
I get negative ay is
equal to negative two x,
I'm subtracting two x from both sides,
minus two x, minus six,
and then I can divide
both sides by negative a,
and I get y is equal to negative two
divided by negative a is positive two
over ax, and then plus six
over a.
All right, so we need
to set up a situation
where two over a is equal to nine over 14.
These two things have
to have the same slope.
And then when we're able
to figure out that a,
we have to verify that
they have different y
intercepts because if
they have the same slope
and the same y intercept,
instead of having no solutions,
they would have an infinite number
of solutions because then it would be
the same line.
But let's solve for a,
so we know that nine over 14,
needs to be equal to two over a.
Or another way of thinking about this,
sometimes people say cross
multiply and all that,
I like to just do logical
algebraic operations.
But we can take the
reciprocal of both sides.
So we could have,
and actually, let me swap both sides,
so we could say a over two
is equal to 14 over nine.
And then multiply both sides by two.
And you're gonna get a
is equal to 28 over nine.
a is going to be this right over here,
this is 28 over nine.
So if I'm under time pressure,
I already see a choice
that's looking pretty good.
If a is 28 over nine,
these two things are going to have
the same slope.
But let's make sure they don't have
the same y intercept,
and I wouldn't do this
if I was under time pressure,
but just for it to feel good about it,
if this y intercept is six over a,
so it's going to be six over 28 over nine,
dividing by a fraction is the same thing
as multiplying by its reciprocal,
so it's going to be the same thing
as six times nine over 28,
and this is going to be
equal to six times nine
is 54 over 28,
which is clearly different
than three over 14.
So if a is 28 over nine, same slope,
different y intercepts,
and you're dealing with parallel lines,
they will not intersect
and you're going to have no solutions.